اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المستمره لتداعيات النزاع المسلح في
السودان الذي يعيش مفترق طرق ويمضي في
رحله اللاعوده على ما يبدو
القوات مشاهدينا اكدت ايضا عبر بيان الله
في صفحتها انها حققت انتصارات وصفتها
بالمتواليه والمستمره ايضا
لبلوغ غايتها وابرزها تشكيل حكومه مدنيه
تمضي نحو تحول ديمقراطي حقيقي
قبل ذلك مشاهدينا اصدر قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان اصدر قرارا
بالعفو عن كل من يضع السلاح من قوات الدعم
السريع واستيعابه ايضا في الجيش الناطق
باسم الجيش السوداني ايضا مشاهدينا النبيل
عبد الله اعلن على شاشه التلفزيون الدوله
الرسمي اعلن ان السودان يعيش محاوله
انقلاب لبتلاء على السلطه
ودعى افراد الدعم السريع الى تسليم انفسهم
ووصف ايضا الناطق باسم الجيش افراد الدعم
السريع بانهم من ابناء السودان ولا مصلحه
لهم في القتال
ان هناك مجموعات مسلحه متواجده في الخرطوم
ربما وغيرها يتم الحديث ربما عن
اقصد ان هناك مجموعات مسلحه متواجده في
الخرطوم ربما وغيرها يتم الحديث ربما عن
[تصفيق]
الان بمطار
الخرطوم المدني
طريقا اه نفسي
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر هذا هو مغرهم الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
اليوم الله بالرب
على شاشه العربيه كما نتابع الجيش
السوداني يقول اعلان الدعم السريع الدخول
في هدنه يهدف للتغطيه على هزيمته الساحقه
ايضا يقول دخلنا مرحله حاسمه وجهودنا
تتركز نحو تحقيق الاهداف العمليه هذا بحسب
بين الجيش السوداني
يقول ايضا سوداني لا علم لنا باي تنسيق مع
الوسطاء والمجتمع الدولي بشان تطبيق هدنه
وقوات السريعه قوات الدعم السريع تقول ان
طائرات الجيش قصفت مركز طبيا في الخرطوم
بحري
مشاهدينا معي في الاستوديو مديره مكتب
العربيه في الخرطوم لينا يعقوب اهلا بك
لينا وحمد لله على السلامه
بدايه يعني لو تابعنا طريقه القصف وما يتم
التعطي معه على الميدان في الاراضي في
خرطوم تحديدا نلاحظ ان قصف لا يقتصر فقط
على المناطق العسكريه وانما حتى مناطق
تبدو ماهوله بالسكان والكرامه على الشاشه
مباشره
ما مرد ذلك واشق اخر ايضا من هذا السؤال
هو ما هو سبب هذه البيانات المتضاربه بين
كل من الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
اهلا بك احمد وبجميع المشاهدين دعني ابدا
لك بالبيانات المتضاربه التي تاتي يعني
نحن نتعامل معها بدقه مثلا حينما قالت دعم
السريع انه دخل منطقه الاستخبارات
العسكريه كان واضح ان هذا الفيديو ليس
للاستخبارات العسكريه انما لمنطقه يتواجد
فيها الدعم السريع وهي مركز الشهيد الزبير
هناك كثير من الفيديوهات التي تاتي منسوبه
الى
مناطق محدده يتم التاكد منها انها ليست
دقيقه ايضا هناك امر اخر بان مثلا هذه
الفيديوهات تم تصويرها في اليوم الاول او
الثاني لكن تم بثها اليوم وهو اليوم
الرابع
هناك كثير من
البيانات التي تاتي هي بصوره مباشره
تستهدف الطرف الاخر وتستهدف ايضا المجتمع
الدولي يعني امس تم مثلا الاعتداء على
سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي كذلك الاعتداء على
عربه تتبع للسفاره على برنامج الغذاء كان
هناك تحديد من قبل السفاره مثلا
المستهدفين هم الدعم السريع ولكن الدعم
السريع ايضا اصدر بريان قال انهم افراد
يرتدون الزي الدعم السريع وليس الدعم
السريع اذا هناك حاله دائمه من من
البيانات والبيانات المضاده ولكن ما هو
الوضع على ارض الواقع هذا ما يكشفه
المواطنون ما تكشفه ايضا معلومات
وفيديوهات وهو بصوره مباشره يؤكد كما ذكرت
انت وهو اجابه على سؤالك الاول يعني هذه
الاستهدافات الان لا تتم على المناطق
العسكريه الجيش سيطره على معسكرات الدعم
السريع لكن الدعم السريع في المقابل هو
ينتشر في الشوارع وكذلك متواجد داخل القصر
ولكن الجيش يحيط بالقصر الجمهوري وكما
ذكرت قبل قليل مثلا لا يرغب ان تحدث هناك
اشتباكات في بعض المؤسسات الحيويه
هل هو ياتي في سياق اقتحام في اطار هذه
الاشتباكات ام تواجد طبيعي لهذه القوات
داخل القصر كما افاد بيان للجيش او متحدث
اسم الجيش يوم امس تحدث انا وجود الدعم
السريع داخل القصر الجمهوري هو امر طبيعي
ومتفق عليه بالتاكيد قبل ان تتصاعد هذه
الاجتماعات ايضا صح مثلا احمد هو متواجد
ويحرس التلفزيون السوداء كان
على الطبيب السيطر على مبنى التلفزيون
السودان ولكن الجيش يسيطر على محتوى وبث
تلفزيون السودان كذلك القصر القصر فيه
مكتب رئيس مجلس السياده وفيه كذلك مكتب
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده كانت هناك قوات
مشتركه ولكن هذه السيطره كانت حتى في
المطار الدعم السريع سيطره على المطار لان
الاعتداء الاول الدعم السريع دخل الى مطار
الخرطوم ولكن اصبحت هناك وكما حدث ايضا في
قاعده مروي هناك لن اقول كروه فروه لكن
الجيش يسيطر ويعود الدعم السريع مثلا مره
اخرى في كثير من المواقع لا يمكن نحن ان
نؤكد بالضبط الان يعني الاماكن التي يعني
يتواجد الان فيها الجيش والاماكن التي
يتواجد فيها الدعم السريع ولكن من الواضح
جدا ان الجيش سيطره على هذه المقار وبث
فيديوهات تؤكد انه الان موجود يبدو كانها
هي معركه كرويفر هذا يدخل هذا ينس
اولا هي رمزيه كبيره جدا انت حدثنا على
المطار فهذا يعني هو التحكم في الحركه
بصوره مباشره يعني حتى الوسطاء كان موسى
فكي مبعوثه الاتحاد الافريقي يقول انه
يرغب بقياده بساطه وانه يرغب بحضور الى
الخرطوم وهذا طبعا لا يمكن الان المطار لا
يعمل رمزيه هذه المؤسسات ايضا حينما يقول
لك او اي جهه عسكريه بانها دخلت الى القصر
فهذا يعني انها تحكمت في في رمز هذه
البلاد فهناك رمزيات كبيره حينما يتم قصف
القوات البريه من قبل مثلا الدعم السريع
هذه تعطيك ايضا مؤشرات كبيره عسكريه
وسياسيه يعني حينما شاهدت انا هذا الفيديو
تاكدت ان الصلح ربما بين الطرفين سيكون
مستحيل يعني اي وساطه يمكن ان يلعبها
المجتمع الدولي هي لن تسهم على الاطلاق في
اعاده الطرفين مع بعضهم البعض لماذا لان
الامر الان لا يتعلق فقط بالق العسكريه في
الجيش او حتى في الدعم السريع الامر الان
اصبح رائعه مشكل داخل المؤسسه العسكريه
ربما بالمقابل ايضا داخل الدعم عمق
الخسائر ايضا لطاله الطرفين الدعم السريع
من جراء هذه الاشتباكات طبعا انا الان حتى
اللحظه احمد ربما نتحدث فقط عن الجانب
العسكري لكن هناك جانب انساني واجتماعي
كبير جدا لهذه الاضرار التي لحقت يعني ليس
ليس كمقر او كمباني ولكن حاله الذعر التي
يعيشها السودانيين الان في كافه المناطق
في العاصمه الخرطوم وكثير من الولايات
السوداني هو امر محزن ومؤسف للغايه لان
هذا القصف المتواصل دون التزام باي هدنه
دعنا نتحدث عن الطرفين لا يلتزمان بالهدنه
هذا امر اثر بصوره مباشره على حياه
السودانيين على الخوف والقلق الذي اصبح
ملازما لهم لمده اربعه ايام على هذه
الاصوات التي تاتي على الحصار الذي يتم
على عدم قدره الاسر السودانيه على التحرك
او على اخذ احتياجاتها على عدم القدره الى
الذهاب للمستشفيات يعني امس شاهدت صوره
كانت مؤثره لشاب حوصرت داخل جامعه الخرطوم
لم يعرف زملائه ماذا يعملوا لان الحصار
كان في كثير من المدارس والجامعات قاموا
بدفنه داخل الجامعه لان لم يقم بامكانهم
يعني تحريك الجثامين هناك اثار انسانيه
كثيره كارثيه الان تترتب يوما بعد يوم على
الشعب السوداني
التساؤل عن البنيه التحتيه في الخرطوم
نتحدث عن المستشفيات
محطات الخدمه محطه المياه والوقود اتحدث
عن
الكهرباء ايضا ما مدى قدره هذه القطاعات
على الصمود فيما يحدث الان
لا يمكن يا احمد ان نتحدث الان يعني يبدو
ان هذه الحرب ستكون مستمره رغم تاكيد
الجيش قبل قليل بانه اصبح يعني قاب قوسين
او ادنى من حسم المعركه وهو الامر الذي
قاله الدعم السريع امس يبدو ان هذه
المعركه ستستمر لماذا مثلا تحدث الينا
افراد من مستشفى في الخرطوم امس قالوا ان
هناك
افراد وجنود دخلوا اليهم وطلبوا منهم خلع
ملابسهم لماذا ليس الفكره اعتداءات مثلا
جسديه ولكن الفكره الحصول على هذه الملابس
ولبسها خلع نعم والدخول الى داخل المناطق
شاهدنا فيديوهات لهذه
الطلقات العسكريه دون ان يكونوا يرتدون زي
مثلا الدعم السريع او حتى مثلا الجيش هذا
يعني بصوره مباشره بان
لاقرب ستكون اقرب لحرب عصابات ان لم يتم
الاستسلام مثلا من قبل مثلا الدعم السريع
طبعا يعني بحسب تقديراتنا ان الجيش لا
يمكن ان يعلن الاسلام فهذا الامر يؤكد
بصوره واضحه ومباشره بان هذه الحرب التي
بدات لن تنتهي في ظرف يوم او يومين او
ثلاثه
الشارع السوداني بحسب متابعتك لينا كيف
يتابع ما يحدث ثم الذي يشعر به هل يقف في
الحياد ام انه ينحاز الى طرف دون اخر
طبعا احمد هذا سؤال صعب جدا ولكن دعني
اقول لك ان تحدثنا عن شارع سوداني غير
مسيس هو يقف مع الجيش ولا يقف مع جهات
اخرى لا يقف مع قاده الجيش لا يقف معها
برهان وقاده الجيش لكنه يقف كمؤسسه عسكري
ولكن ليس كل الشارع السوداني ذلك هناك
كثير ايضا من الشارع السوداني لديهم
مرارات من الجيش ومن الدعم السريع ايضا في
الاونه الاخيره ايضا راينا ان هناك قوه
سياسيه اصبحت تميل الى الدعم السريع وطرى
انها قد تقود التحول الديمقراطي ايضا لهذه
القوه السياسيه جماهير ولديها اعضاء
ولديها افراد بالتالي ايضا كانت لديه فئه
تساند الدعم السريع خاصه تلك التي تتحدث
عن انها ترغب في تحول الديمقراطي لذلك لا
يمكن ان نجمع او نتحدث عن شارع سوداني
واحد او لا يمكن ان نجمع كما كان سابقا
مثلا بان الشارع السوداني يرغب باسقاط
نظام البشير الان هذا الامر صعب ان نتحدث
بلسان الشارع السوداني ولكن الغالبيه هي
تقف مع المؤسسه العسكريه ولاحظنا ذلك في
تغير مواقف كثير من الصحفيين الذين كانوا
في وقت من الاوقات يساندون الدعم السريع
لماذا لان هذا الاشتباك الذي حدث
كان بدءا ربما من الدعم السريع تطور بصوره
كبيره في الخرطوم وفي الولايات السودانيه
الاخرى
يعني بدات الدرجه الاولى الثانيه ثم
انتقلت مباشره مباشره الى المرحله العاشره
وهي اخطر مرحله فبالتالي الان الشارع
السوداني وقلق ومستاء في ذات الوقت مما
حدث بين الطرفين طيب ابي حديثك ايضا عن ما
يحدث على المستوى السياسي ما كان يجري على
مستوى اللجان من لقاءات ومشاورات ايضا حول
الاتفاق النهائي هل كانت كل ذلك او بعض من
ذلك كان يشيء بامكانيه انزلاق الاوضاع الى
هذا المستوى
هل هناك طرف قادر على قلب هذه المعادله
لصالح الامن في البلاد لا يوجد طرف قادر
من القوه السياسيه لكن ايضا كانت للقوى
السياسيه مواقف جيده جدا يعني حتى القوى
السياسيه التي كانت يعني تتحدث بصوره
كثيره عن ان الجيش لا يرغب بتسليم السلطه
هي الان تتحدث يعني
ضروره ايقاف الصراع والحرب لكلا الجانبين
اي انها في هذه اللحظه لا تنحاز لطرف على
حساب اخر طيب
بدينا اتابع بعضا من هذه الاخبار العاجله
التي تظهر على الشاشه شاشه العربيه تباعا
كما نتابع الدعم السريع يتحدث عن هدنه
لمده 24 ساعه والجيش السوداني في ايضا هذه
التهمه ذوي الانفجارات واطلاق نار كثيف في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
بالخرطوم
والجيش السوداني يقول دخلنا مرحله حاسمه
وجهد ان تتركز نحو تحقيق الاهداف العمليه
ميناء شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل كنت معنا مديره مكتب العربيه في
الخرطوم لنا يعقوب تحياتي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في ظل هذا التعقيد الذي يعيشه
السودان اعلن وزير الخارجي الامريكي عن
تعرض موكب الدبلوماسي الامريكي لاطلاق نار
في السودان من دون اصابه ايين من افراده
وشدد بلانكا للصحفيين بعد محادثات وزراء
خارجيه دول مجموعه السبع على ان عمليه
اطلاق النار على الموكب الدبلوماسي
الامريكي هو عمل متهور وغير مسؤول مؤكدا
ان جميع الافراد سالمون وغير مصابين وزير
الخارج الامريكي مشاهدينا حظ طرفي النزاع
في السودان على وقف القتال فورا لتمهيد
العوده لطاوله المفاوضات دعوه خلال اجتماع
وزراء خارجيه دول السبع في اليابان مضيفا
ان واشنطن تجري اتصالات مع اطراف دوليه
لوقف النزاع في السودان
لقد اجيت اتصالا هذا الصباح بكل من قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان والفريق محمد
دقلو حميدتي ودعوتهما لوقف اطلاق النار
لمده 24 ساعه فان وقف اطلاق النار من شانه
ان يشكل اساسا لعوده المفاوضات نتواصل مع
نظرائنا من الامارات والسعوديه وبريطانيا
بشان السودان لقد تعرضت قافله دبلوماسيه
امريكيه ام لاطلاق نار في السودان لكن
جميع الافراد بخير وهذا التصرف طائش وغير
مسؤول
المبعوث عفوا المبعوث الاممي لدى السودان
اكد لاعضاء مجلس الامن ان الجيش والدعم
السريع قام بالتعبئه منذ اسابيع عفوا
مشاهدينا وان كلا الطرفين ليس على استعداد
الحالي للدخول في مفاوضات وفيما يتعلق
بالهده الانسانيه
غير قادره على منح التعليمات لقواتها بسبب
انعدام الاتصال مؤكدا انه في حال استمرت
الاوضاع في التصاعد سيضطر الى سحب
الموظفين الدوليين من دارفور الى الخرطوم
واوضح بيردس انه لا توجد لديهم خطه حاليا
للخروج من البلاد خاصه وان المطاره متضرر
وخارج عن الخدمه كما شدد ايضا على اهميه
ايجاد هدنه انسانيه تمكنهم من توصيل
المساعدات الى محتاجها من السودانيين
اوروبيا مشاهدينا كشف دبلوماسي اوروبي
للعربيه كشف ان سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي في
الخرطوم بخير وان الاعتداء الذي استهدف
مقر اقامته في العاصمه السودانيه اصاب
مبنى المقر الرسمي وكان ممثل السياسه
الخارجي في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
قال في وقت سابق ان سفير الاتحاد في
السودان تعرض لاعتداء في مقر اقامته من
دون ذكر تفاصيل حول طبيعه الاعتداء او
المهاجمين المحتملين
عبر حسابه على تويتر الاعتداء يشكل
انتهاكا صارخا لاتفاقيه فيينا مشيرا الى
ان امن المنشات والموظفين الدبلوماسيين
مسؤوليه اساسيه للسلطات السودانيه والتزام
بموجب القانون الدولي
ونشيل هذه الاخبار العاجله خارجيه سودانيه
تقول ان قوه الدعم السريع تعرض المدنيين
بما فيهم النساء والاطفال للخطر
ايضا خارج السودانيه تقول ان قوه دعم
السريع هي المسؤوله عن استمرار القتال
داخل المناطق السكنيه
والخارجيه السودانيه ايضا تطالب الامم
المتحده بادانه قوات الدعم السريع
لانتشارها داخل احياء سكنيه والخارجيه
السودانيه تدعو المجتمع الدوليه الى ادانه
قوات الدعم السريع
مشاهدينا من القاهره معنا الصحفيه المختصه
في شان الافريقي صباح موسى اهلا بك يا
سيدي الصباح معنا في هذه التغطيه ما يحدث
الان في السودان يثير التساؤلات حول
مستقبل هذا البلد في وجود قوتين
متناحرتين لا تستمعان في هذا التوقيت الا
لصوت المدافع والرصاص كيف ترين مستقبل
السودان وفق المعطيات الحاليه
في البدايه صباح الخير عليكم استاذ احمد
صباح الخير على مشاهدينا الكرام في
الحقيقه المشهد في السودان خطير جدا وانت
تعلم ان السودان يعني دوله مهمه جدا في
الاقليم والمنطقه عموما وفي جوار السودان
الذي يحدوا تسعه دول بالتاكيد الوضع
الخطير في السودان بالتاكيد له انعكاساته
السلبيه على هذا الجوار وعلى الاقليم وعلى
المجتمع الدولي عموما وبالتالي الاوضاع
التي انفجرت في الخرطوم قبل اربع ايام
اليوم الرابع اليوم اعتقد ان يعني لم
نستطيع قراءتها حتى اللحظه بشكل دقيق هي
انفجرت الحرب بدات ولكننا لم نستطيع
كمراقبين بشكل دقيق
نستقرا يعني متى ستنتهي هذه الحرب ومن
مسيطر في هذه الحرب كما تتابع معنا دائما
البيانات والنفي وحتى الان كل ما يعني
نرصده بدقه ان الوضع في السودان وبالتالي
سيكون ماساوي على المنطقه باسرها لذلك تجد
الكل يعني مكمن الخطوره تجد ان دول الجوار
الجامعه العربيه والاتحاد الافريقي والامم
المتحده في استنفار عالمي لما يحدث في
السودان الان وتحولت كل وكاله الانباء
والنظره والبؤره الان هي اصبحت الخرطوم
وبالتالي ده مؤشر ان احنا بصدد يعني منطقه
ساخنه جدا في العالم في هذا التوقيت نتمنى
الحديث بصباحيه حوله من الذي يملك زنا
المبادره لوقف حمام الدم وحمايه السودان
من السقوط في وحل الحرب الاهليه اذا صح
التعبير من القادر على التاثير على جميع
الاطراف تقديرك
في تقدير يعني الى الان الاطراف الدوليه
تحاول كثيرا وفيما هناك مساعي خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه سواء على المستوى
الدول العربيه وعلى مستوى الامم المتحده
وعلى المستوى الاتحاد الافريقي هناك
تحركات كبيره حتى بالامس كان هناك اجتماع
للمجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه بمصر هذا
المجلس سيعقد الا في وقت الخطوره داخل مصر
وكونه انعقد بالامس مساء امس اذا الاوضاع
في السودان وكان يخصصها للاوضاع في
السودان اذا الاوضاع في السودان لديها
تاثير كبير على مصر تخزى من خلاله بعض
القرارات منها عدم التدخل في الشان
السوداني مع يعني الحفاظ على الوصول الى
يعني طاوله حوار واستقرار البلد مصر تحاول
ان تصل بالسودان الى مبادره قبل العيد ان
شاء الله ايضا على مستوى هناك كانت هناك
اتصالات بين مصر وجنوب السودان ايضا
لاحتواء الازمه على خط
الهدنه ايضا هناك السعوديه وبالتالي
المجتمع الدولي يحاول ويحاول لكن في
تقديري ارى ان حتى المجتمع الداخلي او
داخل السودان الاحزاب الداخليه والقوى
السياسيه ليس بمقدورها شيء الان بعد ان
اضاعت الفرصه الذهبيه وقطع الطريق على مثل
هذه الاشتباكات العسكريه العنيفه كان من
الممكن ان تنزع يعني او ينزع فتيل الازمه
قبل اشتعالها ولكن للاسف الشديد
السياسيه الامر كنا نحدد في السودان هي
التي اضاعت الفرصه الذهبيه ام المؤسسه
العسكريه في شقيها اذا كنا نتحدث عن الدعم
السريع او الجيش السوداني
يعني كان بامكانها ان تقطع الطريق على
طميع السلطه حتى في المكون العسكري ولكن
بانقسام القوه المدنيه اعتقد ان انه
احالها الى كره اخرى انتقلت الى انقسام في
المؤسسه العسكريه حدث هناك استقطاب كما
تتابع الدعم السريع كان في اتجاهه القوات
المسلحه كانت في اتجاه لو كانت القوه
المدنيه جلست جميعها ما عدا المؤتمر
الوطني على طويله حوار واحده يعني لم تكن
لتخسر كثيرا الان هي خساره كثيرا وكثيرا
كان هناك تصميم على انتقاء قوه بعينها
وهذا ما جعل السودان يعني ياخذ مخططات
اخرى اخذت بعض القوه المدنيه تلعب بقروض
ضغط بحيث تستقطب مكون من المكونات
العسكريه لم تكن تستقرئ المستقبل بان هذا
يعني انفجار لو حدث سيعرض البلاد الى
منحدر يعني اعتقد ان السودان الان الحرب
التي نراها في الخرطوم العاصمه لم ترى مثل
هذا المشهد منذ عقود طويله وبالتالي لم
تكن هناك رؤيه استراتيجيه للقوى السياسيه
اتعجب كثيرا هل لم تستقرئ ان الدعم السريع
من الممكن ان تكون لديهم مواجهه مع الجيش
السوداني انا احملها بعض المسؤوليه في هذا
في هذه الاشتباكات العسكريه صحيح ان قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني حدثت
الانقسامات بينهما لكن كانت لهما معطيات
لهذا الانقسام كان سببها او احد اسبابها
هو الانقسام المدني والاستقطاب الذي حدث
في المفاوضات التي حدثت من خلال الاتفاق
الاطاري طب يعني بحسبك الحزب السياسيه
تتحمل قدرا ايضا من هذا التوتر المتصاعد
في السودان لكن ماذا عن
التدخل الدولي هل في تقديرك لاعب دورا
ايضا في اندلاع هذه المواجهات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد يعني الانقسام الداخلي
والاجندات الخارجيه بالتاكيد ايضا يعني
لعبت دورا على خط الازمه انت تعلم ان هناك
كان هناك من يدعم برويه واستراتيجيه ولكن
كانت هناك مجموعات او دعني اسميها جهات
دوليه يعني
دعمت اطراف على اطراف وبالتالي كان هذا له
يعني تاثير في الانقسام المكون العسكري
لانه يعني على قدر ما توقعنا لم نكن نتوقع
هذا القرار السريع المنفعل بالحرب يعني
يعني لست اتخيل من اخذ القرار بالحرب
القوات الدعم السريع يعني قرار اعتقد انه
في تقديري جنوني على ان مهما كانت مهما
بلغت قوه الدعم السريعه من قوه ومهما كان
جيش قوات الدعم السريع موازي للجيش
السوداني اعتقد مهما كان المجتمع الدولي
سيقف قوات مسلحه نظاميه ايضا في الاخير في
داخل السوداني حتى لو هناك مجموعات ستدعم
قوات الدعم السريع بالتاكيد الشارع
السوداني في مجملي سيقف مع قوات قوته
المسلحه وبالتالي الى الان لم لم اتخيل
لماذا اخذ هذا القرار الجنوني وعرض البلاد
لهذه السانحه هل كان يتخيل انها كانت نزهه
وانه كان سينتهي من الجيش السوداني مثلا
لم استطيع ان استقرا ماذا يعني
قاده الدعم السريعي يقدمون على هذه الخطوه
نعم هل ترين ايضا صباح يعني في المشهد
السوداني الحالي ما يشبه احد سيناريوهات
التي تعيشها احدى الدول العربيه التي عاشت
ازمات مشابهه في المنطقه
بالتاكيد الصراعات الموجوده ونتمنى الا
تصل السودان لهذه الصراعات سواء في اليمن
او في ليبيا لكن انا اخشى ما اخشاه يعني
اكثر الامثله التي تاتي الى ذهني هو الحرب
التي دارت بين الحكومه الفيدراليه
الاثيوبيه وجيش تحرير التجراي للاسف
الشديد عندما اعلن ابي احمد انه سينهل هذه
كنا نتخيل كما اعلن الناس انه سينهي على
التجار في خلال ساعات ولكن الامور يعني
انا احاول ان اجد لك نموذج مشابه جدا يعني
للجوار السوداني في اثيوبيا على وجه
التحديد وكان ذلك قريبا الساعات امتدت الى
سنتين طبعا خلفت اضرار كثيره ونزوح ومشاكل
الى الان حتى مع الهدنه في اثيوبيا ووقف
اطلاق النار والمبادره الصلح التي تمت بين
الطرفين لكن اثيوبيا تعاني كثيرا
واعتقد ان اتمنى ان ينزلق السودان الى هذا
المنحدر في تقديري ان الشبيه
في صباح انتهت بجلوس الطرفين انتهت بجلوس
الطرفين على طاوله الوفاه
هل تعتقد ان هذا يمكن ايضا يحدث في
السودان
[موسيقى]
انا اتحدث اه قد يكون هناك جلوس لتفاوض
اتمنى ان يكون الاسبوع هذا الاسبوع مثلا
لكن ان تنتهي بحوار بعد عام او اثنين في
السودان في هذا الوضع العسكري والامني
والاقتصاد الهشا اعتقد السودان من الصعوبه
ان يتحمل هذه الفاتوره الباهظه شبهت هذا
التشبيه باديس ابابا ليس لانهم جلسوا
للحوار شبهك بطول المده لان انا يعني كنت
اتوقع ان يقف يعني وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان بعد 24 ساعه او 48 ساعه لكن على
ما يبدو اننا بصدد سيناريو يوما يزداد
يوما بعد يوم هل سيستطيع المجت الدولي
الدول الصديقه للسودان على وجه التحديد في
تقديري لو تكاتفت الجهود خصوصا على مستوى
مصر جنوب السودان السعوديه الامارات هذا
الرباعي الحقيقي الذي من الممكن ان يؤثر
تاثيرا صحيح هناك امريكا وهناك بريطانيا
لكن هذا الجوار والاقليم هو الذي له
علاقات مع الاطراف المتحاربه في السودان
وبالتاكيد من الممكن ان يحدث اختراق في
هذا الملف على الاقل الهدنه التي اعلنها
قائد الدعم السريع والجيش نفاه الان هدنه
24 ساعه على الاقل نسخه القذائف والبارود
حتى نستمع الى الاصوات حتى نسمع المجتمع
الدولي حتى نسمع الداخل السوداني من
الممكن ان تكون هذه الهدنه فرصه لسماع صوت
العقل بدلا من صوت الرصاص الذي بدانا
نسمعه في السودان على مدار 24 ساعه في
داخل العاصمه الخرطوم للاسف الشديد وما
زلنا اسمعه الان في هذه الصور المباشره
الخاصه بالعربيه من الخرطوم اذا شكرا لك
الصحفيه المختصه في الشاي الافريقي صباح
موسى كنت مع من القاهره شكرا لك سيده صباح
الاخبار العاجله الجيش السوداني يقولون
دعم السريعي يستنفروا قواته في نيالا
والفاشر وجيرينا لارسالها للخرطوم وجيش
السوداني يقول نستغرب من حديث الدعم
السريع عن هدنه اثناء حجده قوه كبيره في
مروي سودانيه تقول قوات الدعم السريع تعرض
المدنيين بما فيهم النساء والاطفال للخطر
مشاهدينا ايضا على صعيد الاوضاع الصحيه
الصعب حذرت لجنه اطباء السودان من ان من
ارتفاع معدل القتلى والمصابين من المدنيين
مع استمرار شراسه المعارك بين الجيش
السوداني وبين قوات دعم السريع والفت
تقرير لجنه الى صعوبه اجلاء وحصري عدد
القتلى والمصابين بالاضافه الى العالقين
وقالت اللجنه ان عددا من المستشفيات توقفت
عن تقديم خدماتها اثر تعرضها للقصف
وانقطاع الكهرباء وشح الامدادات ورفض
التقرير استغلال العناصر المتحاربه
للامدادات الطبيه كارتكازات وما اعتبرته
جريمه انسانيه واخلاقيه ودارت اللجنه
الحرب الراهنه المقاتلين بل نشدت
المتقاتلين بفتح ممرات امنه لمعالجه
المرضى والمصابين وايصال المخزونات
الغذائيه والطبيه لمستحقها
اقسم بالله العلي العظيم يا السودان نحن
الدمار ده والله شايفين الدمار
شايفين الدمار يا ناس
اقسم بالله سودانيه احنا
الدمار
يعني
جاي وقتلوا اصحابي وكلهم يعني
قادر نرجع البيت ما عارف نعمل شنو جيت هنا
جيت ما عارف جيت ليه بيتنا
دمار
والله دمار
اقسم بالله والله والله يا سودانيين احنا
اقسم بالله
والله والله
في الاستوديو معي هنا مشاهدينا معي السيد
محمد جميل احمد الكاتب الصحفي الجميل معنا
في هذه التغطيه بالتاكيد دموع هذا الشاب
تعبر كثيرا عما يجيش في صدوره كثير من
السودانيين في هذا التوقيت
كيف تابعت معي ذكره الشاب الان ما هو
شعوره في هذه اللحظات هو كيف يراقب شارع
السوداني ايضا ما يحدث الان في هذا البلد
نعم شكرا لك اعتقد ان هذه الصوره تعبر
اقصد بكثير حتى من الكلمات يعني
ويبدو ان الاحساس الذي نقله هذا الطفل
اساس مؤثر للاسف الشديد يعني
هذا الطفل يتحسر عن اصدقائه الذين قتلوا
في هذه الحرب الظالمه وكذلك يعني يحاول ان
يوصل للراية العام العربي والعالمي حقيقه
الاوضاع في السودان يعني اعتقد ان سودانيه
الان بيعانون يعني بشعور اصلا لم يعني لم
يراهم قبل اصلا علم ويبدو انه لنا كذلك
يعني لانه هذا الصراع الذي استفحل منذ
اربع ايام صراع خطير جدا وصراع
يعبر عن معركه كسر عظم وهذا اخطر ما في
الامر بالاضافه لانه هذا الصراع
لا يعكس تناقضات اساسيه يعني هذا يعني
الدعم السريع يوم من الايام كان جزء من
الجيش او حتى كان له علاقه بالجيش ونحن
نعرف البرهان اكثر من مره كان يقول الجيش
امر واحد
وللاسف الشديد يعني هذا الصراع عبسي صراع
عباسي يدفع السودان والسودانيون يعني صبرا
غاليا جدا للعباسيات هذه واعتقد انه يعني
هذا الامر امر خطير جدا
اخطر من ذلك انه الهشاشه في السودان
الهشاشه بالغه يعني السودان كان هشتا
بصوره غير طبيعيه حتى قبل الحرب يعني
السودان انت تعرف كان في تقارير الامم
بتحب شهر السودان حيكون في الجوع في
السودان يعني فانتحدث حرب كهذه
وتعطل الحياه بهذا الطريقه يعني هذا اعتقد
انه هذا شيء شيء يعني
ازمه الان وصلت الى نقطه لا عوده ام
سنشاهد في يوم ما البرهان وحمتي مع حفظ
القاب يتصافحان من جديد ويتشاركان حكم
البلاد كما حدث في الفتره السابقه
هو اذا لم يصار الى اتفاق او الى حل يعني
الاوضاع نفسها في السودان لا تتحمل ذلك
يعني الاوضاع السودان انت تعرف يعني في
تعقيدات اسميه تعقيدات قبليه
تعقيدات مناطقيه وجهاويه هذه كل التناقضات
اذا كان يعني هذه الحرب ما تتحمل ايام
اكثر من ذلك اذا حتى يمكن لا تتحمل شهر او
شهرين يعني شهر او شهرين البلاد نحن نعرف
الدعم سريع مكون من سنين غالبيه المكونات
الماسيه معينه يعني في
الاطراف السودان او في غرب السودان
بالتالي واضح جدا انه هذه الحرب لا تتحمل
اكثر من ذلك
النقطه الثانيه او المهمه جدا انه هذه
الحرب
هي حرب بينفصلين
الفصلان ليس بينهم التناقض اساسي يعني ما
هذه المشكله بتاع في اليمن الحوثيين
ولا كذلك في بين حزب الله والحكومه
اللبنانيه هذا الصراع لحسن حصلت الان
السودانيين كلهم لم يخرطوا فيه طيب استاذ
محمد يعني
نتابع هذه الصور الان المباشره من الخرطوم
على الشق الايمن من الشاشه نتابع صورنا
جديده وصلت من خرطوم يعني
تبدو فيها اعمده الدخان وهي تتصاعد من
جديد من هذه المنطقه التي تدور فيها
اشتباكات بين
قوات القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات
الدعم السريع وكما نتابع اذا هو هناك دليل
انفجارات واطلاق نار كثيف في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني بالخرطوم تفضل سي
محمد يمكن ان تكمل مع قطع من حديث اي نعم
فانا قلت الحرب هذه لا تتحمل اكثر من ذلك
يعني لحوط الحظ انه الشعب السوداني الحرب
يعني الشعب السوداني ومدرك تماما انه هذه
الحرب كان يمكن
بالاضافه الى ذلك في حركات مسلحه اكثر من
خمس حركات مسلحه لها جيوش في الخرطوم ايضا
كذلك تخرط في هذه الحرب قبل الاستفاده في
موضوع حركات المسلحه يعني انت شرطي لان
هذه الحرب لا تستحمل او البلد لا يستحمل
وضعا اكثر من ذلك لماذا لا نرى او نحاول
ان ننظر بعين التسائل التفاؤل ونقول ربما
ان الجيش قادر فعلا كما وعد على حسم هذه
الحرب في خلال 48 ساعه مضى منها نصفهم
تقريبا حتى الان حل ذلك والد اعتقد ذلك
ليس بوارد لانه الدعم السريع نحن نعرف
تعداده 100,000 له يعني
له امكانيه كبيره في يعني التدريب في
الحركه السريعه فبالتالي امكانيه القضاء
على الدعم السريع حتى في الشهر او شهرين
اعتقد هذا غير يعني غير وارد لانه بس
بحساب بحساب بحسابات
العسكريه طيب هل يمكن ان يتم ذلك بشكل
مرحالي بمعنى ان يتم
القضاء عليه كما وصفت ذلك في الخرطوم وبعد
ذلك ينتقل الجيش الى معارك اخرى في
الولايات تدريجيه بشكل تد والخطوره هذا
ليس يمكن لان الخطوره بين الخطوره انه كل
ما امتد امر الحرب كل ما كان هناك امكانيه
لدخول عناصر اخرى يعني احنا نعرف دارفور
فيها مكونات اساسيه لها علاقه بدعم سريعي
وبالتالي
يعني حتى
الانف سياسي اذا تحولت الى عنف اسني او
الى عنف جهوي يعني سيكون الوضع كارث جدا
لذلك اي امتداد في امر الحرب وينزل باخطار
مهوله جدا لكن انا اعتقد انه في امكانيه
حتى الان كما قال حمدك لم هذه الحرب في
امكانيه الاحتواء لكن بنفس اللحظه ليس
هناك في الداخل السوداني اي مكون بامكاني
انه هذا الحرف وانما هذا الحرب تنهى عبر
مجتمع الدولي وبالتحديدا قبل الرباعيه
الدولية الدوليه التي تضم الولايات
المتحده او المقابله السعوديه
والامارات وبريطانيا هذه الرباعيه اذا قصف
الجهودها وضغوطها طبعا عبر الجزره والعصا
يعني يعني امكانيه حتى الامم المتحده طبعا
هي مخرطه في يعني في الوضع السياسي
السوداني
في العقوبات التلويح بقطع الدعم حتى
التلويع في الفصل السابع هذه كلها اوراق
ضغط يمكن المجتمع الدولي ان ينهي بها هذا
الحرب اذا سكتفي بهذا القدر اشكرك كنت
معنا في الاستوديو الاستاذ محمد جميل احمد
الكاتب الصحفي شكرا
وما عندنا اخواني
مشاهدينا شكلت الازمه الراهنه في السودان
ضربه جديده لاقتصاد البلاد واستمرار
الصراع العسكري قد يجعله من الصعب خروج
السود من الصعب خروج السودان اذا من
الازمه الاقتصاديه الضاربه بجذورها لعقود
مضت التقرير التالي يرخيص الحاله
الاقتصاديه الصعبه التي يعيشها السودان
لا يمكن رسم صوره متفائله للاقتصاد
السوداني في ظل التصعيد المسلح بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قبل هذه
الاشتباكات كان الاقتصاد يرزح تحت سلسله
من الازمات التي يعود تاريخها الى حقبه
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير واستمرت حتى بعد
سقوطه في 2019
الحكومه الانتقاليه التي تولت السلطه بعد
اسقاط البشير احيت امال السودانيين في
تحسن احوالهم اذ رفعت واشنطن بلادهم من
قائمه الدول الراعيه للارهاب وعادت
المساعدات الاجنبيه التي ناهزت ملياري
دولار سنويا الا ان الدول المانحه قررت
تعليق مساعداتها للسودان بعد الاجراءات
التي اتخذها قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان في اكتوبر 2021
وشملت حل مجلس الوزراء والسياده
الانتقاليين مؤكده انها لن تستانف دعمها
للخرطوم ما لم تعد السلطه الى ايدي
المدنيين
الاقتصاد السوداني لم يشهد نموا منذ عام
2019 الا في عام 2021 فقد سجل نموا طفيفا
بنحو 0.5% لينكمش مجددا في عام 2022 صندوق
النقد توقع نمو اقتصاد السودان خلال العام
الجاري ب 2.5 الا ان الاحداث الاخيره قد
تعيد الاقتصاد الى مربع الانكماش ويحاصر
التضخم الاقتصاد منذ اكثر من ثلاث سنوات
فخلال 2022 ارتفع التضخم الى اكثر من 154
في المئه وفي يناير الماضي بلغت تضخم
السنوي نحو 83% لكن هذه الارقام كانت قبل
الازمه الراهنه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع ويعتمد السودان على الخارج لتغطيه
معظم احتياجاته من النفط والغذاء وفي ظل
تدهور قيمه عملته وارتفاع الاسعار عالميا
سجل السودان خلال 2022 اعلى عجز في ميزانه
التجاري منذ 2012 ويساوي الدولار الواحد
حاليا في المتوسط نحو 600 جنيه سوداني
مقابل متوسط بين 18 الى 47 جنيها للدولار
الواحد في 2018 كل هذه العوامل انعكست
تدهورا في مستويات المعيشه وسط تراجع
القدره الشرائيه وارتفاع التضخم وارتفاع
مستويات الديون الخارجيه وغياب
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وبالطبع وفي حال
تفاقم الازمه الراهنه فان كافه المؤشرات
الاقتصاديه ستسير نحو الاسوا محمد زهير
العربيه
تداعيات المواجهات في السودان امتدى
تاثيرها على السودانيين في الخارج حيث عبر
مقيمون سودانيون في مصر عن غضبهم وحزنهم
لاستمرار المواجهات الداميه بين القوات
الجيش والدعم السريع وطالب ايضا بضروره
وقف اطلاق النار والاستجابه الفوريه لجميع
مبادرات التهدئه
في حاله الصوفي في احدى ضواحي
منطقه في القاهره تعكس ملامح وجوه ابناء
الجاليه السودانيه علامات حزن واسى العيون
تتوجه لشاشات التلفاز والهواتف النقاله
لمتابعه اخبار الاشتباكات الداميه في
السودان والحديث لا يتوقف عن مجريات القتل
والخراب
الدنيا رمضان يعني في حد في رمضان بحارب
يوقفوا حرب مساكين ما فيش كهرباء ما فيش
مويه يعني احنا ما واقفين مع الجيش ولا
واقفين مع حماتي نحن عايزين لحد اللحم
السودان والسودان يد واحده اغلب من
التقيناهم لم يخفوا حزنهم وغضبهم الجميع
يحاول ان يتواصل مع الاهل والاقارب
للاطمئنان على سلامتهم صوتي يعني مش
عايزين مش قادر يعني ما قادرين ينوموا حتى
بس ربنا يكون في عونه ان شاء الله يا رب
الكثيرون عبروا عن املهم في ان تنجح
المناشدات والمحاولات العربيه والاقليميه
والدوليه للوصول الى وقف لاطلاق النار
والحد من نزيف الدماء نتمنى من اخواننا
العرب المنطقه الجاليه العربيه كل ما
يجفهم معنا في كل شيء ان شاء الله يا رب
العالمين نرجح كل المجتمع الدولي
والاقليمي
تقف وقفه واحده اتجاه خروج من الازمه
الحاليه هسه حاليا قاعد في الخرطوم
الاحداث وتداعياتها اثرت على مجموعات
كبيره من السودانيين والمصريين العاملين
في مجالات النقد البري بين البلدين شغل
بتاعنا الضرر من 3 ايام بالضبط او من ايام
الواد اختلف
سواق مثلا ومعايا عربيه ومعايا واحد صاحبي
معي عربيه بنشيل شغل بنودي شغل الشغل عدد
ابناء الجاليه السودانيه في مصر يتراوح ما
بين خمسه الى ثمانيه ملايين نسمه رقم مرشح
للزياده في حال استمرار ت دهور الاوضاع
السياسيه والامنيه والاقتصاديه احمد عثمان
العربيه القاهره
[موسيقى]
المشاهدين الى هذه الاخبار العاجله
الوارده تباع على شاشه العربيه الداخليه
السودانيه تصدر قرارا بانتهاء بل بانهاء
انتداب جميع ضباط الشرطه بقوات الدعم
السريع وايضا الجيش السوداني يقول ان
الدعم السريع يستعد لاستقبال مساعدات
عسكريه في مطار مروي ويقول ايضا الجيش
السوداني ان دعم سريع يستنفر قواته في
نيالا والفاشر والجنينه لارسالها للخرطوم
ونستغرب من حديث الدعم السريع عن هدنه
اثناء حشده قوه كبيره في مروي وخرج
سودانيه تقول ان قوه الدعم السريع تعرض
المدنيين بما فيهما النساء والاطفال للخطر
مشاهدينامي الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسله
العربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم واخر
ما توفر لك بمعطيات حتى اللحظه
[تصفيق]
هناك مستجدات كثيره لكن ابرزها كان موضوع
البيانات التي صدرت من الجيش السوداني ومن
وزاره الخارجيه بيان وزاره الخارجيه التي
دعت فيه الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي
والمنظمات الاقليميه لادانه التمرد قوات
الدعم
القوات المتمرده بانتشارها واستمرارها في
القتال في المدن والمناطق السكنيه ايضا
الخارجيه المجتمع الدولي بان يتدخل ويعني
يحضر عمل هذه القوات باعتبارها قوات
متمرده وايضا تستمر في القتال في داخل
المدن والمناطق السكنيه وهذا بابرز ما ورد
في بيان وزاره الخارجيه ايضا مدير عام
الشرطه يصدر قرارا بنهايه
والدعم السريع هذا ينصحك في المكتب الصحفي
للشرطه اكدت به انهاء
جميع الضباط المنتخبين للعمل بالقوات
ايضا القياده العامه للقوات
اصدرت بيانا
القوات المسلحه قال نستغرب
مثل
العدد لمعلومات
تامين هبوط طائره العسكري من جهاز اقليمي
مرتين هكذا قال بيان القوات عفوا سالم كي
نسمع الجزئيه الاخيره بشكل واضح يعني هل
يتحدث عن الجيش عن طائرات طائره عسكريه
ستحضر دعما للدعم السريع في مطار مروي
نعم هو يتحدث على ان العدو بحسب وصف
القوات المسلحه يتحدث عن هدنه في ظل
معلوماتنا المؤكده بحجزه قوه كبيره في
مروي لغرض تامينهم طائره مساعدات عسكريه
من جهات اقليميه وكذلك استنفاره لقواته
للحضور للخرطوم هذا بالنيابه
وذكر الجيش السوداني هذا لا يحل مرتين طيب
هنا تتحدث سالم ما زنا نسمع طبعا لاصوات
الانفجارات ودويا المدافع يعني هل
هناك معلومات حول المناطق التي تتركز فيها
هذه الاشتباكات حاليا هل هي نفس المناطق
التي تدور فيها الاشتباكات منذ صباح هذا
اليوم ام ان هناك نقاط جديده اصبحت ساخنه
في هذه اللحظات
ذات النقاط احمد التي تجمع فيها
الاجتباسات في بحري وفي درمان وفي
طيب هل توفر اي معلومات اضافيه حول
الاصابات حول السقوط القتلى حول وضع
المستشفيات في الوضع في الوقت الحالي
لا ليس هناك جديد في هذا الملف احمد سوى
ان هناك سقط المناشدات التي تستمر ملاحدات
من
المنظمات الدوليه ومنظمات هنا محليه
ومنظمات كذلك دوليه مناشده
بامس يتم فتح مسارات فقط لايصال المساعدات
وبعد ذلك يمكن ان يكون الوضع افضل من هذا
بكثير على كل حال انا الان هناك مستشفيات
خارج الخدمه هناك مستشفيات ايضا
تحاول ان تكون داخل الخدمه وايضا ربما
تعود الحركه الطبيعيه اذا خفت وتيره هذه
الاشتباك او تعودي شبه طبيعيه صحيح طيب
سالم هل رصدت حالات نزوح باعداد كبيره من
العاصمه والى اين تشد الرحال يعني في
خريطه البلاد
يعني بشكل كبير حتى هذه
اللحظه
ربما
التوتر والقلق لدى المواطنين من هذه
الازمه وكذلك الاستماع اليدويه المدافع
وغيرها ربما تجعل المواطنين قلقين جدا في
مساله الحركه نفسها هذا الامر ربما هو
الذي يجعل مساله النزوح ايضا غايه الصعوبه
في هذه اللح
لكن بشكل عام هناك بكل تاكيد تخوف من
المواطنين من الخروج التخوف من
يقتربوا الاماكن التي يتم فيها الصراع
والنزاع او
هي مسرح لهذه الاح
داث طيب سالم بالنسبه لوسائل الاعلام
الرسميه وغيرها في البلاد يعني هل تعمل في
ظل هذه الظروف وكيف تعمل وهل منها هو معطل
تماما عن كيف يبدو الوضع
نعم الان انا الان في المحطه الوسطى ببحري
وهناك اعمده الدخان كثيفه جدا من قلب
المحطه الوسطى لعله حريق او انفجار لا
اعلم عن تفاصيله لكن تتصاعد السنه الدخان
بكثافه بالقرب من المحطه الوسطى في بحر
وهي ليست بعيده من جسر الماكينه الرابط
بين
الخرطوم
والرابط بين الخرطوم ومدينه بحري نحن الان
في امام هذه السنه الدخان التكلفه لعله
حريق هنا في هذا المكان في المحطه الوسطى
ببحث حركه الناس في الشارع سالم كيف تبدو
المحطه الوسطى خاليه الان من الماره لا
توجد اي اثار لوجود مواطنين على الاطلاق
وايضا هنا فقط
السنه الدخان الان هناك بعض المواطنين
قليلين جدا يحاولونه احتواء هذه
هذا الحريق الان نراهم امامنا يحاولون
احتواء هذا الحياه
طيب اشكرك اذا الخرطوم وكنت معنا مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي
نذكر مشاهدينا بالاخبار العاجله الوارده
على شاشه العربيه كما نتابع الان هناك
دوري انفجارات واطلاق نار كثير في المحيط
القياده العامه للجيش السوداني بخرطوم
وكما نتابع في هذه الصور اتفاق اعمده
الدخان في بعض هذه المناطق في خرطومه
نتحدث عن اشتباكات تدور في منطقه بحري في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش ايضا في محيط
المطار
وفي محيط القصر الجمهوري ايضا الداخليه
السودانيه اصدرت قرارا قبل اقل من ساعه
بانهاء انتداب جميع ضباط الشرطه بقوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني يقول ان
الدعم السريع يستعد لاستقبال مساعدات
عسكريه في مطار منوي
والجيش السوداني ايضا يتحدث عن ان الدعم
السريع يستنفر قواته فينيالا والفاشر
والجنينه لارسالها للخرطوم
مشاهدينا وصلنا لنهايه هذه الساعه من
تغطيتنا في هذه الساعه الساعه المقبل اذا
معكم الزميل خالد مدخلي متابع طيبه
[تصفيق]
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات